Elon Musk arrives at court in Los
Angeles the entrepreneur due to face the
British diving specialists he accused of
being a pedophile vernon's Werth was
among the teen credited with
coordinating the rescue of 12 boys
trapped in a flooded cave in Thailand in
2018 in a now-deleted tweet mr. musk
described him as a pedo guy the outburst
from the Tesla chief executive appeared
to be in response to an interview where
mr. Unsworth criticized his decision to
send a mini submarine to the cave to
help mr. musk told the court it was
wrong and insulting so I insulted him
back it was an unprovoked attack on what
was a good-natured attempt to help the
kids he cast his own word choices of
frivolous and generic insult from his
childhood in South Africa not a literal
one but the British divers legal team
argued he was in fact using his platform
to damage the Explorers reputation and
paint him as a pitiful the billionaire
who is being sued for defamation and is
worth around twenty three billion
dollars as previously said he will not
settle after more than three hours of
cross-examination he's doomed back on
the stand today
woody Leyland Sky News Washington